[Musique]
ça s'est passé il ya à peu près plus de
10 en moins de dix ans je dois avoir à
peu près 13 14 ans à l'époque où je
m'entendais très mal avec mes parents
dont je passais quasiment tous mes
week-ends chez ma grand-mère à paris et
puis j'ai eu l'idée je pourrais te
passer dans les grands magasins avant
d'aller chez elle et je là j'ai dû
commettre le mont seul vol le plus beau
et plus cher parce que j'ai piqué un
chemisier au rayon comme en haute
couture que j'ai pris sous le bras donc
un beau un très beau chemise et qui se
servent à manger mal et du tout et en
sortant parce que je l'avais mis toute
façon bien en vue sous mon bras ni
cacher ni rien du tout donc je me suis
fait prendre par la surveillance du
magasin et je me suis retrouvé au
commissariat de police avec
les clochards et compagnie et ceux qui
avaient commis tous les lébous larcins
et ma mère est venue me chercher deux
heures après et on s'est expliqué après
pour pour qu'elle sache pourquoi j'avais
fait ça et c'était pas réaction par
rapport à mes parents la situation que
je suivais avec eux j'ai poussé la porte
d'un poussant la porte j'ai vu un mètre
de moins et un plumard est dedans il y
avait un couple qui dormait et à côté de
là à côté du lit à 10 cm 2
l'entrebâillement de la porte il y avait
une chaise visiblement sur les murs et
aériens n'y avait pas de chaîne stéréo
il y avait pas de coffre fort il n'y
avait pas de lingots d'or et une chaise
avec une veste en velours posé là je dis
à mon pote qu'est ce qu'on fait on
parlait tout doucement qu'est-ce qu'on
fait alors allez viens on s'arrache
c'est tout ils sont dedans ils dorment
ya rien à tirer et tout vient on
s'arrache et dinan merde on n'est pas
venu pour rien
métro compte ou peut-être dans la vaysse
devient la feuille et les tulles et où
j'ai pris l'air est délicatement sur le
palier j'ai fouillé les poches
il n'y a rien dedans sauf une pauvre
montre mais nulle genre je parle montady
ça qu'elle donnerait un bracelet en
tissu tout déchirer et comme vraiment un
symboliquement il fallait j'ai volé une
fois quelque chose d'important dans un
cas c'est vrai mais bon sans effraction
parce que c'est de les fractionner la
porte j'ai pissé la montre j'ai laissé
la baisse sur le palier parce que je me
suis dit le fait de la remettre sur la
chaise peut-être ça va les réveiller
j'ai trop peur pire les partis anti
avalanche et le lendemain j'ai dessaoulé
lendemain j'étais malheureux mais comme
comme rarement j'étais malheureux quoi
j'étais mal je me dis merde je suis un
nul et seule fois de ma vie où je vais
faire un truc vraiment interdit
dangereux enfin non j'avais fait des
petits trucs mais premier cas et j'ai
réussi à voler rhin pauvres plus pauvres
que moi à la limite en plus ça montre
j'ai filé à mon frangin qui lui est bon
il ya eu le même essayé de me payer un
beau bracelet est tout bon j'ai volé les
pauvres pour filer orishas nuls toute ma
vie j'ai honte j'ai encore honte
si le mec que j'ai volé ce jour là se
reconnaît je suivais une montre en or
aujourd'hui pour me faire pardonner
parce que
c'est épouvantable un jour comme ça je
ramassais sur la route des choux de
bruxelles qui était tombé un panier ou
d'une charrette alors y en a 20 de temps
en temps je me promenais avec mon père
et ma mère puis j'ai trouvé que c'était
plus simple d'aller dans le champ où se
trouvaient les choux de bruxelles parce
qu'il y en avait davantage
là j'ai pris une bonne paire de claques
l'électrochoc du pauvre j'ai appris
qu'elle ait pas de petits larcins que le
net et c'était quelque chose d'invisible
ça c'est un souvenir de 10 ans puis
après j'étais avocat pendant 20 ans
s'était pas dégraissé omar b et puis
japon des partis et ces deux ans après
alors que je travaillais dans
l'administration j'avais une place
tables pin vie comme les autres
c'est à ce moment là que les flics qui
m'ont arrêté bon on a eu des fins j'ai
eu des périodes fastes et pinet fast
pisser dans les période néfaste où j'ai
volé mais pour bouffer uniquement le vol
pour moi c'est nécessité ce qu'on nous a
refusé on prend pas ce que ce que la
justice nous refusons prend on arrivait
juste à passer nos petits doigts
et puis on tirait ses bonbons les uns
après les autres on a bien pris une
dizaine peut-être chacun on les a mis
dans notre poche évidemment on ne
pensait pas que c'était un vol s'était
pas du tout même pas chapardage bon mais
c'était c'était une chance qui était
arrivé à ce moment là mais tout de même
bon les nos valeurs de notre éducation
ou la crème de je-ne-sais-quoi nous a
fait rentrer dans l'épicerie et puis on
est allé dire à l'épicier amsalem il ya
une autre ou dans
dans votre vitrine il ya des moments qui
sortent et n'a peut-être qu'ils peuvent
vous en prendre sa réaction a été
automatique
il est allé dans la vitrine il a pris
une poignée de bonbons il nous en a
donné à chacun et cette réaction m'a
beaucoup beaucoup touché voyez ça je me
demande même si ça n'a pas influencé mon
attitude mon comportement maintenant
lorsque je rencontre quelqu'un qui a
pris peut-être un étalage tout en ne
l'excusé pas mais disons en essayant de
de ne pas le loranger ne pas le
marginaliser de lui expliquer d'être
beaucoup moins pas moins sévère mais
disons de lui faire comprendre de
manière à ce que l'on recommence part
peut-être un jour je vais dans un
magasin de disques dont je tairai le nom
naturellement il ya 8 10 ans et je
rentre je me dis je vais m'éclater je
vais m'acheter je prends moi
bakhit coffret de disques que j'avais
envie de tas de coffrets jeudi je
m'éclate et je claquais mon feuilleton
pigeon vicois et je prends une une masse
de deux coffrets alors je choisisse pour
deux plombes
j'avais chaud pour cent plus anciens
connaissent j'en avais un paquet comme
ça et je l'avais comme ça et je sors
j'arrive à la sortie enfin vers la
caisse alors ça se passe en une façon
seconde parce qu'il n'y avait rien de
prémédité
j'arrive pour elle à la caisse il était
12h30 normal car pas un rat ni à la
caisse n'y a nulle part et j'arrive la
caisse et sur ma droite et la sortie est
en phase est celle et tout droit donc à
partir de cette seconde là j'ai volé je
dis [ __ ] je sors je suis sur le
trottoir je me souviens très bien
c'est là j'ai eu peur sur le trottoir je
me suis dit il va y avoir une main qui
va s'arrêter qui va se poser là j'ai
continué émerveillé que personne ne
m'arrête et c'était mon vraiment mon
premier vol sérieux quoi mais pas
prémédité quoi vraiment dans la foulée
et après j'ai eu peur est respectivement
jir de ce que j'ai fait parce que c'est
il ya toujours un risque
c'est terrible de truc absolument 40
morts non non c'était vraiment un hasard
non ça m'intéresse pas moi ce qui
m'intéressait cette volée 600 milliards
c'est sûr mais voler des conneries comme
ça ça m'intéresse absolument pas vous
dire quand on va aux craintes quand on
pense qu'on va au bagne pour un miche de
pain enfin voir jean valjean et ça
continue il faut pas voler ne volez pas
les mecs ne volaient pas ou alors volé
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
[Musique]